so today I want to talk to about three
different Ferraris one a 1977 one 1997
and one a 2017 each 20 years apart and I
want to give you stat which is how fast
did each go zero to 60 and this is what
we have a 1997 ferrari 301 when zero to
sixteen 8.1 seconds which today 8.1
seconds is a lifetime but in 1977 super
fast then a 1997 Ferrari 456 one zero to
sixty four point nine seconds
okay that's almost twenty F seconds
faster than a Ferrari not 2017 488 the
gtp goes zero to 60 in 2.9 seconds super
fast now if you look at that trend we
went from eight one four nine two knives
so let me ask you let's go to twenty
thirty seven what do you think a Ferrari
is gonna be doing at twenty thirty seven
you think it's gonna do is zero to
sixteen point nine seconds can you
imagine point nine seconds you may say
there's no way in the world here's point
nine seconds ready set go
you just won 60 that's point nine
seconds now someone back at eight point
one set four point nine is impossible
someone at four point nine said two
point nine is impossible and then
someone today at two point nine says
point nine is impossible but what's the
point with this this is an entrepreneur
channel what point am I trying to make
is it's a Ferrari endorsement that I'm
making not at all this two point you the
point is everything in your business
today in the processes that you have
whatever it is from selling from point
of contacts to sales from receiving the
sale to processing the business to
delivering the business to following up
with the client to hiring firing
training whatever process you have
that's tied to a timeline what can you
do to compress time frames meaning what
can you do to go from doing in a week to
doing it in three days to getting done
in the day what can you do to get it
from 24 hours to 12 hours to six hours
to three hours what is it what areas of
your business can you completely
compress time frames in today and by the
way somebody may look at this and say
Pat there's
no way in the world I can compress any
of the time frame to my business well
that's exactly what a lot of auto
dealerships and automakers said back in
the days when Toyota came out and said
we're gonna solve every single issue in
59 seconds let me explain too in their
assembly line when cars would come
through and every time there was an
issue Toyota was known for having this
bill you would told the bill and a
supervisor would come and they would fix
that car's issue their average time was
59 seconds which is why they produce so
many different efficient cars so fast
and they dominated the marketplace and
everybody's talking about Toyota's a
genius Toyota is this you know they
compress time frames by the way look at
this a fast-food restaurant who
dominates McDonald's dominates you can
make all the commercials about them you
can make a documentary called a
supersize of whatever you want to do
with McDonald's they're still gonna have
40,000 McDonald's around America alone
and Kix
Wendy's tell jack-in-a-box Burger King
not because of the food not because of
the service biz because they deliver
their product to you the fastest more
than anybody else from the moment you
order from the moment get the food and
leave it's the fastest look take a sheet
of paper make a list ask what can I do
to make the process faster and don't say
it's impossible then get a committee and
ask them to put input what can we do to
make this thing faster once you do make
it faster let me put it to you this way
however fast your business is growing
today it's not even close to how fast
your business can grow if you figure out
ways to compress time frames in every
aspect of your business that is tied to
process or timing you will be
shell-shocked by the results you start
getting with your business once you're
able to figure out a way to compress
time frames